اعلنت وكالات استخبارات غربيه ان جهه
سيبرانيه مدعومه من الصين تسللت الى شبكات
للبنيه التحتيه الحيويه في الولايات
المتحده وحذرت منها هجمات مماثله قد تحدث
في جميع انحاء العالم وفي تحذير مشترك
قالت سلطات الامن السيبراني في كل من
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وكندا
واستراليا ونيوزيلندا انها رصدت مجموعه من
الانشطه السيبرانيه على صله بمجموعه
التي تحظى برعايه الصين
وكانت شركه مايكروسوفت قد كشفت النقاب عما
سمت نشاطا الكترونيا صينيا خفيا استهدف
بيانات البنيه التحتيه الحيويه في
الولايات المتحده
ان الهجوم يهدد باحداث اضطرابات في البنى
التحتيه الحيويه للاتصالات بين الولايات
المتحده والمنطقه الاسيويه في الازمات
المستقبليه واكدت مايكروسوفت ان المجموعه
منذ منتصف 2021 وقد استهدفت البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه في جزيره غوام الامريكيه
حيث تمتلك الولايات المتحده قاعده عسكريه
رئيسيه في المحيط الهادئ
في المقابل اتهمت الصين الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها بشن ما وصفتها بحمله تضليل واقلت
الخارجيه الصينيه ان التقارير عن هجمات
سيبرانيه برعايه بيجين مجرد مزاعم وهي
وتقارير غير مهنيه على الاطلاق
تحالف العيون الخمس هو اكبر منظمه
استخباراتيه في العالم ووكاله الامن
القومي الامريكيه هي اكبر منظمه قرصنه في
العالم ومن المفارقات انهم اصدروا بشكل
مشترك تقارير معلومات كاذبه اما بالنسبه
لمشاركه بعض الشركات هذه المره في اتهام
الصين فالظاهر انه بالاضافه الى الجهات
الحكوميه تقوم واشنطن ايضا بتوسيع قنوات
جديده لنشر معلومات كاذبه